nice to meet you you too how are you
watch your guys videos one of you I'm
one of your fans oh thank you yeah I
watched a bunch of your stuff um also
well that one said he told me when Sonny
told me that we were you know we were
going to be meeting up and I saw that
your video to us so thank you for that
too yeah that was cool so how long have
you been doing YouTube and stuff
um I've done it when I when I first came
to Islam 10 years ago I started like
about six months after
I wasn't really planning on doing it but
it's just some of my friends were like
you know why don't you try it I was like
nah they were like just try I I started
doing it on my phone and then from there
it just grew when I saw people
benefiting and yeah just from there to
school it was like 2013
wow that's really cool so now this is
your full-time job is YouTube and
content creation
um to be honest I I'm a I was an Uber
driver I used to Uber so I I didn't
actually
um monetize my um channel for a long
time because obviously as Muslims we
believe that uh earning from ads that
are not permissible for example if
there's ads that pertain to alcohol
interest uh sometimes ladies wear were
always kind of uncovered so due to that
I didn't monetize my channel so I didn't
really do it um I never had the
intentions of doing it for money to me
it was just like something I love doing
and when I came to Islam because I lived
um
I started we're recording but um
if the only thing you want to say off
the Record we can either stop or tell
them to keep it off the Record okay not
a totally fine you can keep I just
wanted to know okay so yeah before I
came to Islam because I used to live a
life of clubbing partying you know I
come from like my dad's atheist uh my
mom believes in God so I come from like
a non-muslim family so when I came to
Islam you know I you know I lived that
lifestyle so to me it was a big change
so I really changed my way so to me you
know I wasn't really like that money
motivated so when I started YouTube I
didn't monetize for a good couple of
years but after YouTube now gives you it
allows you to block certain ads so I can
block
um as alcohol gambling interest-based uh
ads and a few other stuff so I go to my
Google AdSense and just block Those ads
and since then spoke to my teachers and
they said yeah it's it's fine you can
monetize it now so it's not something
that I because I do work on this idea
thank you for thank you for actually
answering the question I was going to
ask you about your background before you
came to Islam
um but also I I didn't realize that you
could choose ads which ads you don't
want because I I have that same concern
and I haven't really had the chance to
even have that conversation with sunny
like there's certain things like I don't
want any part of
so I you know I was I really respect
that yeah does it even affect your RPM
or anything or it just pushes out
different ads
to be honest I don't know I've never
like experimented where I'm like I'm
thinking would
would
like I don't know would you should pay
me more I don't know maybe because
there's certain things like when you put
gambling alcohol so these are things I
think maybe I don't know but I it might
do or they just maybe just use different
ads that um so yeah I don't really know
I'll be honest with you like sometimes
yeah it's just yeah I have no idea I've
never like monitored it like it's not
something I wanted to uncheck or like
how much am I making because I like for
me personally it's very important for us
for myself to have the right intentions
in what I'm doing so I don't want it to
be I don't want a connection between
money and what I do because it's like um
is that you know Christians do
missionary missionary activity so to me
it's like I try to divorce the money
side of it
um from what I'm doing and obviously you
have a lot of things from like as
YouTubers you have the fame you have the
money you have the attention on the
opposite gender so these are three
things that you have to be careful to
because as Muslims we believe that every
action you do is based on its intention
so we believe the first three people to
enter Hellfire on the day of judgment
will be Muslims so I'll be a Muslim who
um gave in charity but God will ask him
what did you do for my sake he will say
oh God I gave in charity you say no you
didn't you're lying you did it so people
say you're a charitable man you're a man
who likes to look after the poor and the
second man he will ask him what did you
do for my course you'll say oh God I I
went to a holy battle for you yeah and
he will say you're a liar you did it so
people say what a brave man you are and
the third one was someone who would
teach knowledge Islamic knowledge be a
Quran or something let's say I do and
God will ask what did you do for my sake
and he will say I taught this and this
he said no you've done it so people can
say what's a knowledgeable man so to us
intentions are very important because it
might be that God is
using me but I have wrong intentions and
I'm doing all of this for money and the
fame and many people will benefit and
many people might come to Islam but I'll
be bankrupt at the end of it so to me my
intentions are very very important
um so I just try to make sure that I'm
doing it for the right reasons and I
remind myself on a daily basis and I
pray to God that God allows me to do
this for the right reasons
hmm that's a very very interesting point
the intentions thing because a lot of
people don't even really know why they
have intentions for the stuff they do so
if you're doing a lot of good like
donating to charity and stuff because it
makes you feel good is that bad so like
what exactly do you need to be feeling
inside or what motive to do that stuff
to be okay with God you know do you know
what I mean because if it makes you
don't have the I don't have the the
Muslim answer for that but I I have the
Christian answer for that I think that
if things are um
just to stay specific
um if you're doing it and it makes you
feel good it depends on that feeling if
you're doing it again for the attention
that you're getting and that's the
tension that that's what making you feel
good that's not that's not good because
they say we say for charity you you
don't go you don't tell anybody what you
did you know you just go out you do
charity you give and you keep it quiet
you keep it on the download so if that's
the case and you're really doing that
just truly because you want to help
people
that's God working through you I believe
and I believe that that feeling comes
you know God gives that to you so that
you continue to do good work
is my is my Christian answer on it
very profound that's actually very
interesting because to us it's very
important as well where we try to um
hide our Good Deeds so because I'm
someone who's in the public
there was a moment of time where I
really was in Conflict like am I doing
this for the right reasons and it was
really eating me up and I thought to my
I spoke to my teacher and I said you
know what I'm thinking of leaving
YouTube and he's like why I said because
I don't think I might not be doing this
for the right reasons because one day's
my one day my intentions are for me one
day is against me so there's so many
factors that play and he said to me he
said look this is the work of Satan you
know so you cannot if you're doing
something good you can't just leave it
you could it could be you know the
Whispers of Satan so he said to me look
and and this was very amazing reminder
to me he said to me why don't you focus
on your private deeds and I thought wow
that's actually very profound because
anything that I Do privately be it
charity be it how I treat my wife be it
to how I'm with my kids how I'm with my
mom uh because like especially parents
because Allah says in the Quran after
you it tells you to worship him to be
obedient to your parents so it's very
important for us to be very obedient to
our parents especially our mothers as
well so I started focusing on my private
needs because that's between me and my
Lord good so not many people know that
so I'm sure of that I know I can't be
showing off because no one can see it so
it just pushed me to focus on my private
deeds and it helped me to increase their
kindness towards my mother or my wife or
my kids or be it like not that give that
much charity but you know whatever I can
do so it's it just focus it made me go
down the route of doing more private
Deeds
interesting and where'd you say you're
based out of
uh what do you mean where I where I base
it did you say no like where do you live
or where'd you grow up London London
London okay awesome I'm originally I'm
originally Kurdish from Turkey
nice wow are there a lot of Muslims in
in London do you go and you get
recognized a good amount yeah yeah
you're doing certain places like if you
came to East London there's a lot
predominantly Muslim population so it
depends depends where you go but yeah
yeah London is very it's it's quite
diverse so you get a lot of um yeah yeah
where are you guys from in America uh
we're in Florida right now we just moved
to Florida from Boston so and uh it's
you know it's 88 degrees and sunny out
every day oh well you're lucky it sounds
it sounds Sunny yeah Florida
it's a totally different world uh well
geographically it's um you know they
have the Four Seasons very brutally cold
Winters you know you're getting
blizzards and dealing with ice and snow
all the time all winter long
um and you know the change of seasons
brings a lot of you know uh natural
beauty that we don't have that that is
pretty steady down here in Florida uh we
don't have any real natural disasters up
there and politically though it's it's
very very very very very very liberal
and to the point of it is driving people
out so Florida is you know definitely
more of a conservative state with I
think for for me uh people who were
politicians and rules and way of life
that I agree with more a little bit more
reserved and conservative so
that's another big difference there's a
lot more to say about the differences
but so what what made you guys start
YouTube I'm very interested it's a very
it's a brilliant collaboration by the
way you guys very it's fun to watch uh
what made you guys decide okay you know
we're gonna start YouTube
so it was my idea you know my mom didn't
come to me asking to make reaction
videos yeah so I had you know I was I
was in a company around six months ago
had an exit and I wanted to go put my
focus full time into content creation
again so what I had like a whole pretty
diverse plan I wanted to make my Academy
teach people how to use social media
edit online and then also start my
agency so that way I have a direct
funnel of high quality editors it's
pretty weird but I have to go too in
depth on that so I had to figure out a
way to go viral as quick as possible to
get people inside of my Academy so what
I did was I thought of mom reacts and
Andrew Tate was the most trending thing
at the time so I hopped on that made a
YouTube video about it
um and the first literally the first
video on the channel got about 200 000
views within weeks so then from there
rather than trying to switch off and
make my own stuff we kind of just ran
with it and then the Islam the Islamic
videos started I don't even think a
month ago I just made one and it was
going super viral and people kept asking
for more so then I just kept making them
and to lead back to your thing about
intentions some people would comment
about I mean I would think about my
intentions with making this kind of
stuff too you know because I don't want
to just be milking it for views that's
not my goal my goal at all with it
um so people would comment about that
like you're just making videos for views
but I thought it was cool for like
Americans to show their you know their
perspective of learn like literally
their whole journey of learning about it
regardless of if we converted or not
just so people could see what it looks
like for a typical American to learn
about it
yeah that's interesting
you know what it just it kind of um it
weaves in with intentions and what you
were saying before is what I'm about to
say I you know growing up Catholic I 12
years of Catholic school I never I knew
that we were supposed to give you know
given the put an envelope or some cash
in the Box every week at church and all
that but I never I never was taught the
concept of tithing are you do you know
what tithing is so tithing is you of you
give ten percent oh every dollar you
make comes off the top and goes back to
God so it goes to your church or you
know your synagogue or whatever your
model and I don't know if you guys do
that but what I've been learning now you
know later in life is is that there's a
whole there are philosophies in the
Bible about money and how you make not
just how you make it which is what
you're talking about and what you're
talking about but also what you do with
it and it basically says that we none of
the money's ours
so we are just stewards of God's money
and so if he brings money to us it's
what are we doing with it are we sitting
on it are we doing good works with it or
you know are we spending it on alcohol
and drugs and hookers what are we doing
um and so and so he so when we take 10
off the top from the second we get it
and we give it back to God he's you know
it establishes his trust in US
and it's a way to ensure that he will
give
um
you know that that he will provide for
us and even if you feel like you don't
have enough like I can't take 10 off
I'll never make it and you know but but
he says it says that this is actually
the only place in the Bible where you're
almost invited to test god well you know
and be like all right let's see if this
is true and start giving your 10 back to
him immediately and seeing making sure
and then you end up having more than
enough anyway and it's amazing and it
what they say is anybody who's ever
started doing that has never regretted
it and just never turned away from it so
if we look at that money as not ours as
Gods you know and you and you weave that
in with the intentions you know there's
there's a tremendous amount of good that
can be done there but it also puts a
tremendous amount of responsibility on
everything we do
interesting you know we have we have a
similar like in the in the Quran Surah
baqarah chapter 2 verse 245 it says who
is the one who would give Allah a good
loan so that Allah multiplies it for him
many times God Allah withholds and
extends and to him you are to be
returned so it's very interesting what
you just said because it's a very
similar concept and with us it's that um
what's obligatory on every Muslim man
and woman is called the zakar so it's
2.5 of your wealth so uh whatever you
earn like net profit you pay 2.5 to the
poor so that goes to the poor that's
zakira we also have something called
sadaka so this is something that is
voluntary that you do and the prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him said that
charity will never make you poor so we
have an interesting concept so sometimes
we think to ourselves logically if I
have
200 pounds in my account or let's make
it dollars two hundred dollars in my
account so
if I give so if I had an atheist friend
they would find what we do weird like
Christians and Muslims because if I said
I've got 200 pounds in my account and
I'm going to give a hundred pounds to
charity he'll be like you're broke why
would you do such a thing because we
believe in the metaphysical reality the
Unseen it's God's promise that the more
you give in charity the more it will
return back to you so it's actually that
when you're not giving is that when
you're taking it away from yourself
so rather than giving what what would
you think as an atheist because if he's
in Paris is where he thinks you know
it's this world that's all we know and
there's no Hereafter he will think
you're stupid to give a hundred dollars
you're giving 50 of your wealth when you
don't have nothing but to us the
Christians and the Muslims because we
believe in the metaphysical Reality by
not giving were taken away from
ourselves yeah I know exactly what you
mean but when we give we are returning
and I've seen this with my in my life
where I don't remember a time where I
would give 50 pounds in charity except
it comes back to me how not flying money
just comes and lands on my mind
a job opportunity will come somewhere or
something and I'll be like oh my gosh
anytime and that's why it reminds me
what you said as well that not a single
time that when you put your trust in God
because this is something that requires
Faith it's a faith matter you have to
have faith when I give and that's what
it is it's God Almighty is the one who's
created the heavens and the Earth he
can't provide for you and the moment you
put your trust in him you will see that
go back to you and another thing your
dear Mother Said by the way she looks
like your sister I think I'm gonna have
to say is it
thank you no I was yeah I didn't have
him that young either but thank you so I
so that's like really a compliment thank
you
oh Elena sister Elena yeah so thank you
you talked about money belongs to God
that's very interesting because if we
think about it check this out and I
found it very profound
money belongs to God we belong to God
the universe belongs to God God is
telling us spend what belongs to me
money for my sake given in charity and I
will give you Paradise the money belongs
to him we belong to him Paradise belongs
to him he wants us to use what belongs
to him for his cause for his sake and he
will give us paradise and to me that's
like the most merciful merciful thing
ever because
nothing belongs to me he just wants me
to spend what he's given me for his
cause for his paradise and when you look
into the Quran when God Almighty talks
about the people who enter the Hell Fire
allow you to the word saying that and
this is what they deserved but when it
comes to Paradise God Almighty doesn't
say deserved why because Paradise you
guys believe in grace in Christianity
right you believe in grace we only enter
Paradise via the grace of God so some
some people have a misconception that as
Muslims that we believe praying fasting
doing all this kind of stuff is what
will enter us the paradise not
necessarily it is ultimately God's grace
and mercy because there is nothing that
me and you can do to earn Paradise the
paradise is a gift from God however when
it comes to Hell Fire Allah says it is
what they earned meaning the people in
the Hellfire will never complain to God
and say God you've been Injustice all
they will say is please give us another
chance meaning they acknowledge that
they deserved where they ended up and
sometimes people say to both Christians
and Muslims what kind of a God is this
that if he's the most merciful why would
he punish somebody for eternity and I
say to myself well instead of
questioning God what kind of a wretched
person was that individual that they
went bypass all of God's mercy and
bounties and chose Hellfire
yeah
that's what you were very you know
shocked about at first you're like that
doesn't sound very loving for Hellfire
but I mean I guess it does make sense
like if you run around being an a-hole
your whole life
like there's there's consequences to
that you know what I mean and I'm sure
God shows himself tons of times to be a
good person so if you just couldn't
constantly refute that do you know what
I mean right you have you have well the
way they if you're talking to them like
oh I forgot I always forget he's uh just
um so you know you put it you you put it
in a way that that really resonated with
me just now uh but I have heard you know
other other Renditions uh you know of
this Hellfire and it just seems really
extreme so you put it in a way that
really makes sense to me and the thing
is yeah so Christians will say when they
when they finally come to Jesus and they
come to you know a really a relationship
with him that he you know they didn't
realize that Jesus had been chasing them
and then they look back across their
lives and they look at all the
opportunities that they had prior to
come to God and you know people that may
have brought it brought to them and
invited them to church or some you know
kindness that came out of nowhere or
thing
um so when you finally come to it you
you really have an Awakening on that but
if you ignore that your whole life yeah
do you deserve to go to heaven I also
struggle with it though because Jesus
taught us about ultimate forgiveness
that you know he is he his grace is so
generous and so loving and you know they
that that he loves us all through our
trials and no matter what we're doing
and no matter how horrible we're being
so I have a trouble reconciling that
kind of unconditional love with then
when you get to the door you get kicked
you know down the stairs do you
understand why I would have to struggle
I think you're talking about Luke
Chapter 19 Verse 27. if I'm not mistaken
where it talks about the end of times
and it gives a parable of the king and
those of those people who did not allow
me to Reign Over them bring them here
and slay them it's a parable but he's
talking about at the end of times there
will be judgment and of course there
will be people who are going Hellfire
which is very important because we do
hear like obviously like God Almighty
like Jesus and his love but there is
hellfire in Christianity as well so the
concept with us is like Allah says in
the Quran I think it's in chapter four
verse 147
um that Allah says that what will I get
out of punishing you so God Almighty is
is it's like um if you're if you're a
grown man and you're a boxer and you
have a little kid kicking your feet
just you're not going to be like okay
look I'm gonna I'm not even gonna touch
you I mean why would I why would I get
out of punishing you I mean God doesn't
want to punish anybody so this
misconception where people think that
God is a god of wrath and God is looking
to this is the opposite because if you
look into the Quran every chapter except
one starts with Bismillah
Allah the most merciful the very
merciful so God Almighty wants you to
know he could have used God has many
names and attributes he could have used
any he could have used the Avenger or
like the one who he could have used many
but he used that name specifically to
show his mercy so there is many uh
Hadith like for example that we know
like for example after one of the
battles Prophet Muhammad peace be upon
him there was a lady who lost a child so
she was very concerned you're a mother
you would relate to this yeah so lost
your child and you're frantic looking
for him where is he and the prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him had his
companions and he said you see that
woman he said do you ever think that a
woman would throw her child in the
Hellfire and they said no wait look how
frantically she's worried looking for
him he said Allah is more merciful to
his servants than that woman is to him
to her child so the point is what that
God Almighty wants Mercy
he wants Paradise for us all but if
individuals make decisions if they know
for example that and we and and I think
Islam is the only religion that has this
concept that if a person believes Islam
is the truth they know deep inside
they're like okay this religion is the
truth okay I know but I'm not going to
follow it because arguments say I don't
know because they are there so that
whatever it may be that is what is and
being a disbeliever because you know
it's the truth but you're choosing not
to follow it for a variety of reasons
but if you think about it there's freak
there's conditions here in Islam and I
think Islam is the only religion that
has this which is if a person hasn't
heard the message of Islam
if a person is has Insanity a person who
hasn't reached the age of puberty and
some Scholars even say if somebody has
has heard the message of Islam in the
wrong way for example 9 11 these people
are so the scholars say that on the day
of judgment they will be tested so we
believe in Islam an atheist a Christian
a Jew a Hindu a Sikh whoever it may be
have a possibility of entering Paradise
because if they didn't hear the message
of Islam it's unfair for God Almighty to
punish them in Hell Fire when they
didn't hear the mystery of Islam so
Allah says in the Quran we will never
punish a nation until we send the
messenger so unless they heard of it and
they rejected this different story but
if they haven't heard of it then why is
it fair for God to punish somebody for
eternity for something they never heard
of and never knew of so in Islam they
would have their
um a specific test on the day of
judgment
to prove that you know they believe in
God so that's one concept that we have
it makes sense that's nicer than our
court systems you know we don't you you
can't plead ignorance when you're
standing before a judge you know so I'm
sorry I didn't know I wasn't allowed to
kill that lady you know so that's that's
that's really nice that God is much more
merciful than yeah and also like the the
thing that you mentioned um sister is
that you said that Hellfire to me is
what I used to think this is more like
why Eternal Hellfire like and sometimes
we don't fathom and understand what
should blasphemy is it's a very severe
thing and I thought to myself and maybe
this might make a bit of sense so if we
said for example in Islam we believe God
Almighty is at God's discretion for
punishment so for example if you're
driving down in Florida you'll have a
sign that says if you cross the red
light you will get fined up to ten
thousand dollars yeah now that is at the
discretion of the judge the judge can
totally say to you know what I'll
forgive you this time or he can say I'm
going to give you the ten thousand pound
fine or I'm going to give you five
thousand pound fine oh you know what
don't do it again so it's at the
discretion of God so there are
prescribed punishments but is that the
discretion of God Almighty yeah no it
makes sense the biggest sin in Islam and
Christianity and Judaism is blasphemy
towards God which is shirk have you
heard of shirk
or if we have I forgive me I you know
it's a whole different language it's
hard to remember I'm not that as well
trust me I forget a lot so the thing is
it's associating Partners to God so for
anyone to say for example the Pagan
Arabs before Islam came they used to
have Idols they worshiped so if you
think about these Arabs Pagan Arabs they
used to worship idols but they affirmed
Allah they said we believe in Allah we
believe in he's one but we just use
these Idols to get closer to him because
we feel inferior we're Sinners so that's
what made them disbelievers because they
would associate Partners to God Almighty
so shirk is that anyone that says no God
God is a woman or God is a man or God is
a tree or this is God so that's his ship
so that is the severe sin that lands
someone in Hell Fire forever
so I was thinking to myself how does
that make sense now if you think about
it if we was to say okay let's be just
here for every time somebody commits
[ __ ] 24 hours
and we would it be fair to say that we
put him in Hellfire for 24 hours would
we say that's fair 24 hours of
shirk 24 hours of Hellfire argument's
sake yeah okay you can say okay at least
that's a bit okay at least for a sake of
conversation sure yeah well one day for
one day now the thing is with God is
that God knows that if he was to send
that person back to Earth and let that
person live for eternity they will be
committing that sin eternally so that's
the reason why the punishment of
Hellfire eternally for that sin is
Justified because if we brought Hitler
back
he would do the same thing again most
likely and you know for example in in
the court I don't know if you guys
watched that movie um you know that guy
who got accused wrongly there's a
discussion on it I forgot it
there's multiple movies like that yeah
there was a very interesting one I've
got the name of it yeah but he he spent
25 years in prison came out and then he
got done for another one and it was it
was really uh popular on Netflix it was
very interesting oh they're making a
murderer yes making them out that one's
crazy yeah yeah that was that was mad so
if you think about it the court system
does what anyone that's a repeat
offender you're in prison forever
because they know that you are going to
cause Menace to Society so I think maybe
that's one way of maybe making us
understand Hellfire and Christianity and
Islam
to me I don't know yeah yeah no no no
it's really helpful what what I you know
one thing that I'm hearing um not in
this conversation but in general is
about you know how Jesus was not God
and so that would put him in that in
that category of you know a pagan Idol
in in the context of what you're talking
about now
um but every time I hear that I do a
little bit more research on it on the
Bible where he he actually did say he
was God and he was one with God and he
and The Trinity to me does
make as much sense as it can you know
um
and so I also you know have have faith
in in your faith in the sense that not
as a not as a Muslim woman but as you
know I respect it and I and I like the
basic tenets of it and where we where we
share common ground and I just can't
help but to wonder
if we're both right you know
um or we can both
eat despite the discrepancies in our
religions both end up in the same place
in that same Heaven because the God is
the same and maybe he's just speaking to
different people in you know in
different languages so to speak and the
two religions are just different
languages am I making sense yeah you
know like maybe some people will
resonate more with the message of Jesus
being his son and one with him and maybe
some people resonate more with the Islam
message but if we're really living the
same values
and being charitable and kind and not
judging each other not playing God down
here I mean ultimately we're doing the
same thing and we're achieving the same
goal I'd like to think the same thing
like because I mean in Christianity what
is it you just have to accept Jesus as
your lord and savior to get into heaven
you know so I feel like
that doesn't make as much sense compared
to like just doing good and then
regardless of what religion it is if
Hinduism was the truth or whatever but
that also says just do good by God with
good intentions your whole life
then like I feel like they're not gonna
be like oh but you didn't you didn't go
by this the correct label like that's
just not how I look at it but if you
live by God's laws and for God
I feel like the God that I know is
merciful and loving and will say you did
it kid because you did it your way but
you know you took you took one of the
several paths I laid out for you and I
and I and I I would like to think that
that's true and I've just totally made
that up
um you know in this exploration over the
past few weeks as we're learning more
about Islam because learning more about
Islam is um also prompting me to study
more about you know dig deeper in
Christianity because I hear a lot of you
know uh this is nonsense that's nonsense
and so I'm digging and I'm actually
moving deeper into my Christianity
because of it but also really having a
deeper love and respect for Islam which
I never had you know so which is really
cool
so I think that he may be just giving us
all options and as long as we pick one
of them and follow it truly they all
lead to him
it's interesting like I totally
understand where you would be coming
from with that like definitely you know
I would I not want that God Almighty
send different messages and that they
all led to him I would pers I would
personally resonate with that and be
like I would love for that to happen
but I look and I'm like okay there has
to be one truth if there are multiple
truths because if you think about it if
Islam says argument say God is one and
there is nothing like him Christians say
no it's the Father the Son and the Holy
Spirit then you go to the Hindus and
they say no we have one million kinds of
different gods or then you go to for
example the Sikhs they are all given a
different definition to God how can they
all lead to him when one is saying that
the god that we believe in for example
is a million gods and these are our
Idols arguments like an elephant with
six arms and then somebody comes in the
Pagan Arabs come and say no no we
believe in this Idol here and then we'd
have the Muslims come and say no God is
one there is nothing like him what
happens is that there has to be one
truth otherwise we will have no Truth
For example you say you live in Florida
and it's a liberal state
we got out of the liberal State and came
down to Florida where it's uh
Boston was liberal yeah yeah super
liberal okay okay that's fine so
interesting so where you was if you
think about it the the Liberals are
pushing this agenda because their world
values based on the two goods Pleasure
and Pain so the thing is here they are
coming and now as you know which we're
both conservative I'm assuming yeah so
we both have something in common so
imagine they come and say look this is
our truth we want to teach young kids
about transgenders about homosexuality
and that this is fine that a child who's
four years old decides if she we would
come and say no that's wrong but they
could turn around and say well hold on a
second this is our truth and this is our
way of then what happens is we can never
find truth because we don't have any
foundations because if we accept
everyone's worldview somebody might come
and says oh you know I believe incest
should be a right you know but you look
at even the lgbtqt they even reject the
the ones who want ancestral rights to
have incest they say no no this is
terrible and then we're like well what
you're doing I thought love was love so
they even have truths that they stand by
so to me it's like if we don't have one
truth it is impossible for us to find
the truth but personally like yeah it's
very interesting no I I oh go ahead no I
was gonna say because I've said the same
exact thing about them because at first
it was the LG and then like the LGB LGBT
lgbtq plus and it's just like it doesn't
stop that's my that's what I mean I
always say the lgbs need to get the heck
away every time plus is because they're
just off the rails everywhere you add
they add 10 more and then it's like you
got to be accepting and then they come
at it with the Trojan Horse they start
teaching your four-year-olds in the name
of acceptance
you know why though because the thing is
when you don't have objective truths and
objective morality as men and Mankind we
would make laws left right center and
this is what we're seeing today red pill
I believe it's another Extreme as
Muslims we don't really accept it right
people is a whole different extreme of
vilifying woman we reject that then you
have feminism men are the problem so we
reject both we say the more we follow
man my man-made laws the more we're
going to be confused that's why God
Almighty has sent down us Revelation so
we can follow his the morality that he's
given us which is objective which is
free from Human uh in um interference
and one of the reasons I'll explain
which why I came to Islam is because if
you think about it we all think we're
free right you do you think you make
choices yeah I disagree to an extent for
example are you saying that your
societal pressures doesn't have an
influence on you like for example
especially when it comes to uh females
I'm reading a book it's called a beauty
sick I recommend you guys to read it's
very interesting so it just talks about
the pandemic of beauty sickness within
females and I'm thinking to myself where
is that stemming from girls feel uglier
fatter they starve themselves to have
the perfect body they don't leave the
house without makeup they spend hours on
end they walk out on the streets with
mini skirts and this much heels and it's
freezing so the question anybody asks
with the same man in mind is why would
anybody choose to do that is
well that's the thing though a lot of
people say for themselves but none of
them that none of them females go to bed
and be like you know I'm gonna wear
makeup it's always for some reason when
they're going out and about but the
point I'm trying to say is besides the
female is it happens with men I was a I
when I before I became a Muslim I used
to go to the gym I used to wear specific
clothing which I was so uncomfortable in
but I wore it because I couldn't yeah so
it's not just a female issue yeah as
then we go through it I'm gonna go to
the gym for myself yeah okay whatever
yeah you're going to the gym to uh
attract opposite gender yeah I get a
haircut every week okay yes now it's
more like yeah for myself obviously I'm
you know we believe Allah is beautiful
and he loves Beauty hopefully I'm
beautiful I don't know about that's
maybe a discussion that we can have but
the point is the point the point is what
we all think we are free a philosopher
said something very interesting he said
man is Born Free but in shackles
everywhere so if you think about it
before I came to Islam I used to say my
masters are the clothing that I wear the
opposite gender the money the extra
hours that I do the cars that I drive
these are all my masters because I am
living for them and I always used to
live for other people I said to myself
you know what I'm going to free myself
from these shackles and become a slave
because I'm bound to be a slave to
something either my Society or whatever
it may be I'd rather be a slave to the
one who created me because he deserves
My Worship and when I started to worship
Him and become a slave to him when I
found my freedom because now I don't
live for others so that's why it's very
important for us to have that connection
with God almighty and what he wants
because if we have multiple truths then
you've got lgbqt a b c d e f g and then
hey LMNOP so it's it's it's it doesn't
stop it okay no you make all good points
all of it right but so so I want to get
back to the multiple truths but I also
want to you know get back to the the
shackles thing when you put all your
focus on God the shackles just fall away
and we started this conversation with
you saying how you when the YouTube
started to blow up you you started to
have internal conflict about it you know
you start thinking about what other
people think you can't help it and that
is like your like your teacher said that
is the devil getting into your head and
we have to constantly fight that like
you have to just keep refocusing on God
all day long but that's when you don't
need the flashy car you don't need the
you know you don't need the six inch
stiletto shoes you don't need to you
know just be fully consumed with how you
look and what others think all the time
it's very fraying very very yes I'm
wearing makeup right now but you know
I'm still I'm just that's fine you know
but it's not like honestly like we we
know we know you look good without it
anyways thank you you know you know like
it's not you know overly I it's still
pretty low-key compared to what I see
some of these young girls doing with the
contouring and the fake fake eyelashes
and fake eyebrows and I'm like what are
you doing girls you know what do you do
when you're beautiful stop it so the
Simplicity
um in choice that just comes naturally
from focusing on God is really freeing
and relaxing and it makes those those
false Idols go away but back to the one
truth so I guess when I'm talking about
it I'm talking about
[Music]
um
biblical truth from the Old Testament
2000 years through the Quran right
um and you know some of the ancillary
materials around those that have
developed the ones that have been given
credibility
to me those are you know Judaism
Christianity
um
Islam and I don't know enough about
Sikhism and Buddhism to say if they fit
into where they where they fit into that
but I do believe that they may be
mentioned in the Quran if I'm not if I'm
correct
um like Buddha I believe I believe
someone told us Buddha was mentioned in
the Quran but it could be
um
some fire worshipers Majors is mentioned
yeah so if we talk about those three
religions which all believe in the same
God yes that's really what I'm talking
about when I talk about we are all on
the same path are taking different paths
to the same city to his City the guys
over here uh worshiping
um
drugs alcohol partying money uh the ones
over here are worshiping the sun and the
you know the dog I I think they're on
they're they're on paths to a whole
different city uh than the ones that
we're on the path for just for clarity
I'm not talking about everybody talking
about those of us those of us who
believe in the one God that's
interesting because Allah talks about
that as well and Allah says tell the
people of the book yourselves that we
come to let's come to Common terms
between us and you but we worship God
alone so Allah acknowledges that that's
the reason why the Jews and the
Christians and the medians like the Jews
in the Christian specifically we are
allowed to marry from you we're allowed
to eat your meat we are allowed to
um you are allowed to live amongst us so
Muslim empires when they would expand
and take territory you are not allowed
to force conversion to anyone so
Christians and Jews will live with us
and if a Muslim was to go to the
Christian area where they have their
churches and let's say they drink
alcohol he's not allowed to break the
alcohol he can't if he does he has to
pay for that so the thing is and we even
like accept like living in harmony
together
um so Islam acknowledges that all Islam
says is that you have the Old Testament
you have the New Testament the Quran is
a final Testament what it does is just
affirm what came before it and because
we believe Satan deviated many people
it's that we want to call the people
back to worshiping God all Islam is just
saying is that
just acknowledge that God is one because
the moment you say God there is more
than one God the question that begs is
okay who created that good life as a
mother you're a mother yeah to this
handsome boy here yeah this is you know
let's get me be excited here yeah yeah
and he gets his looks from his mom of
course I tell him every day he hears it
plenty yeah
so imagine like I said this before in
the video that I've done
imagine he turns around to you one day
and says you know what I'm gonna go and
thank Ali I believe Ali is the one that
deserves my Fang my gratitude I'm gonna
go work for him and I'm gonna look after
him when he's old
as a mother who has looked after him
nurtured him fed him when he was a baby
changed his nappies
it will be so hurtful for you that he
totally forgot about you gave the credit
to Ali Ali is an absolute nobody and
he's given all the credit as if you will
think either this guy he's lost his mind
somebody has done some magic on him
there is something definitely wrong with
him because why would somebody with a
sanity with not suffer from Insanity
choose to turn around and especially a
mother yes fathers and mothers they're
both the same yes but the process is
going to give emphasis on the mother so
imagine him turning around you how would
you feel would you not feel betrayed
yeah of course I would feel that I and I
would also feel that I failed
okay so what we will see is that with us
when we see anybody not just Christians
look whoever there are some Muslims who
do some weird stuff they like they go to
they pray to the prophet Muhammad which
we believe like they literally think if
I preach him here we say that is wrong
as well because what you're doing is as
if you're seeing the prophet Muhammad is
all hearing and he can hear me here so
what we're seeing is that imagine
when instead of thanking God because
Jesus himself said like in the Acts
chapter 2 verse 22 here
um Jesus of Nazareth a man chosen by God
with wonders Miracles and signs which
God did by him and you are a witness to
it so we know he went to the mountain of
Gethsemane and he prayed so we see in
many instances where somebody came to
him and said oh good Master what must I
do to have eternal life he said why do
you call me good there is only one good
and that's quote I understand some
Christians say no that was his humility
but the point is what for some reason
Jesus always is giving credit to the
Father the Father the Father the father
like any time if if I'm if she's achieve
something in my life and I know deep
down it's someone behind me let's say my
brother who's giving me that success and
I say look I understand you guys
appreciate what I do but this is the guy
behind the scenes who's doing the real
job so to us it's like to get the credit
and imagine have you guys seen the the
picture they took of the universe
recently yes amazing
just imagine and have you guys seen that
video which shows um our planets
compared to a different planet and
compared to the Sun have you seen that
yeah that blows my mind I keep watching
and I'm like that is crazy just imagine
the one that created all of that
we turn around and say uh we believe
Muhammad is God
that is the greatest that's that's where
we're coming from I get it no and I
totally get that but Jesus did say that
he was that he was one with God and he
was God also and he came and he didn't
just say you know
he he did have to pray to the Father
which it is hard to understand right
because there was unity and division at
once and that is hard for us and it is
hard for even Christians to fully
understand and we have to take some leap
of faith there but he he was able to he
did at certain points reveal himself the
way same way God had revealed himself to
Moses he had been prophesized to be
coming back to becoming as uh you know
as God he had also he forgave sins
um and he was not no one but God could
do that he also you know changed uh and
or I don't know if it was clarified or
changed um you know Sabbath laws
and practices so he did things that only
God could do and said things that only
God would say and that is you know
historically why I I look at the more I
research it the more verification I have
for that and it you know so then to say
but I also understand if he hadn't done
that why would I worship him and not God
that would be blasphemous that that
makes perfect sense but I do believe
that he is one with God
okay so you know if a religion came and
said for example Hinduism and they said
we believe an argument say A God Called
Ganesh and Ganesh he did Miracles he
forgave people's sins
um he done Miracles and many other stuff
why would why should I imagine myself
I'm let's say I'm not a Muslim why would
I choose Jesus over Ganesha because if
they come and say our books say he was
sent to Earth as a not as a man but as a
woman and he done Miracles he done
things only God can do and in our books
it says that he said he is God as a
bystander who's not I'm looking to
choose which religion why would I choose
Jesus over Ganesha like what is it
that's unique because the same thing so
in the very just refresh just clarify
for me exactly what what religion he he
was I mean what people he was coming to
and who who was the God the same God so
imagine so imagine an argumentative yeah
Hinduism yeah and they say they have a
god called Ganesh yeah and Ganesh does
exactly I identical things to Jesus he
claims to be the son the daughter of God
he claims that he died for the sins of
the world he's done Miracles and forgave
sins and done all of this kind of stuff
and he and she had a miraculous birth
what why would one choose Jesus how
would I know which one is the truth like
why Jesus but not Ganesh or why Ganesh
but not Jesus
I guess I can't really uh even answer
that without doing more homework on
Ganesh right so the things I learn about
Jesus is are are
really well
um well account you know well-documented
accounts that are supported by you know
you know historian very after great
great
um what's the word I'm looking for
scrutiny scrutiny scholarly scrutiny so
that I'm not you know looking at you
know something that was in a thousand
years later that could very well be just
somebody's opinion
um you know we're talking about you know
gospels and like the man I forget his
first name Josephus who was a political
historian during during Jesus's Lifetime
and he brought he brought some knowledge
to the table and he didn't really
comment on religion he didn't do a lot
of writings unless somebody came to the
scene and made a political Ripple and so
he wrote a lot about John the Baptist
and then about Jesus so you know there's
there's sources that I'm pulling from
that you know I feel give a lot of
credibility to it
okay so you know you know for example
you know that Jesus and Christianity
came about I think over a thousand years
later after Judaism so Jews can make the
same claim and go why would we have a
law and by the way Jews and Muslims
they're quite similar when it comes to
the concept of God
um so why would we follow something that
came later because a lot of people say
oh but Islam came later but if we look
at Judaism before Christianity
Christianity came way after and if we
look at all the prophets in Judaism and
in Christianity
all the profits from Adam
all the way downwards and some people
say this like some people come and say
oh Muhammad came and changed everything
you know and we we say well okay let's
put this two tests the prophet Mohammed
peace be upon Him came and said worship
God alone okay what did Adam say worship
God Alone not the Trinity but what did
Noah say worship God Alone what did
Prophet Lord say worship God Alone what
did Abraham say worship God alone
so there was a consistency throughout
history this concept of worshiping God
alone so the point I was saying about
connection Jesus is as a bystander the
first thing that I would ask is well
hold on a second guys Ganesh would you
say is the daughter of God okay and is
God okay Jesus is the son of God and his
God okay my criteria for the truth
before I came to Islam I read the Bible
I actually
read it for quite a long time I can
remember reading it my criteria was very
simple
I couldn't believe it's impossible for
me to believe that God Almighty became
his creation so from the get-go I would
have to reject Ganesh and Jesus as being
God because we accept Jesus as a prophet
he's a mighty Prophet so what I would
have to say is on what basis do you
reject that for example I would say for
example do you accept that God has no
beginning and no end
I mean it must have no beginning of no
one yeah absolutely yes well yeah I
would I mean that's what I was taught
and that's a reasonable to believe
yeah so do you believe that God Almighty
is all-knowing
yes and they're all powerful
yeah so so these are basic concepts that
we as human beings we have innate this
position to believe that God Almighty
has these attributes now I would have to
say okay
Jesus he was crucified on the cross does
that show him all powerful or weak at
that moment of time I would say week but
when he was taught is that Jesus was 100
human and a hundred percent God so
something that's kind of out of like
truly you know and that he could have
gotten himself off of that cross at any
moment but he chose to he chose to stay
there because
the the point of it was to teach us uh
forgiveness
and to die you know I I you know they
take they tell us in church you know he
died for our sins you know to help to
you know cleanse our sins he took on all
the suffering
uh that we deserved so that's why he did
that but he was resurrected three days
later you know to prove again his
ability you know that his God true but
what can we say this can we say God God
does Eternal be finite at the same time
kind of God be infinite and finance at
the same time
he died and Ken was resurrected and that
was his whole point that he he wasn't
finite so so so the fact that he died
shows his final he was finite because
the fact that he died if he was infinite
if he had no beginning and no end there
would not be a point of him ending So
when you say when we say there's a
belief that God Jesus is fully God and
fully man it's a contradiction because
what it is is like he was all-knowing
and not knowing at the same time or
powerful and not powerful at the same
time he uh had a
um he's Eternal and not Eternal at the
same time so to us it's like how do
those two merge together like either
you're all because arguments say
um can God cease to exist
no I don't think so why not like I can
say why not why can't God cease to exist
because we know that that doesn't
benefit the uh the attribute of God how
could God cease to exist if he sees to
exists who runs the world right that's a
common we don't it's it's something that
we in in it's in our intuition right so
we say Okay God cannot die can God make
a rock so big that he can't lift
well no there's nothing that he can't do
so so that so that alone is is proof to
me that alone it supports the argument
that he can send a human
um a representation of himself
to teach and to and to break the mold
and and just because the other prophets
didn't didn't claim to be God doesn't
mean that you know there were prophecies
coming that Jesus was coming that the
Messiah an anointed one was to become it
was coming so it really this it
shouldn't be that hard to believe that
he came on the scene and made the claims
that he did okay so my claim is the
following if we are going to believe
that God can become a man so what I'm
saying is why don't we also agree that
he can cease to exist or he can make a
rock he can't lift why do we deny two
but except one so what I'm saying is why
do we say he cannot cease to exist so we
can say a condition God cannot cease to
exist and I go you're absolutely right
he cannot cease to exist can he make a
rook so big he can't lift no for example
can God lie
um I I I I don't think so but I don't
know I don't know
can he can he yes would he know right
okay
so what we're doing is now we're putting
some conditions on good you cannot lie
he won't lie
um Can can he um lift the rock so big
make a rock so that he can't live no can
he cease to exist no okay so we have
given some commissions to God because
we're like that's not godly like God
wouldn't lie God wouldn't cease to exist
but why is it that when it comes to
being a man we're like oh no he can do
that so this is a problem that we as
Muslims because we're like it goes
against his nature because Jesus he
didn't know the hour he said and he says
it it just doesn't say I don't know the
hour he says not the angels in heaven
not the son
but the father it's like who is that not
you are you not saying not me but me
knows like not me so to us it's like in
his nature we cannot accept him to be
divine because he's shown us traits but
he's not Divine that's the reason God's
innate nature is what all powerful or
knowing cannot cease to exist cannot lie
cannot make a rock so big he can't lift
himself well and good why is it that
when it comes to Jesus it's like well we
have an exception here I think yeah no
I'm just I I'm not buying it and I'll
tell you why I he
because he is all-powerful and
all-knowing he came he he lived as a man
and and performed Miracles and taught
things and moved mountains that no other
man had ever been able to do before he
raised men from the dead and that was
God you could say that was God working
through him but he was he is also
it's hard it's hard to explain it in a
concrete term you know if we were
talking about organic chemistry you know
we could we could have a really you know
scientific granular conversation that
would would make sense but
to you know and again I'm still
relatively new in my deeper Bible
studies but it makes sense all those
reasons that you just gave that he is
all-powerful all-knowing you know that
he is honest you know that he he would
never make a rock that he couldn't move
you know like the rock of the Tomb that
was moved away
um you know all of those things actually
kind of can also be used to verify
Jesus's
and his ability to be both you know how
can you how can he be both because the
thing is if he's all powerful
he he could he would never be in a
situation where even if he could stop it
he would never be in a position where he
is being crucified so even if he said
okay he had the power but the fact that
he allowed them to overtake him the fact
that a God says okay if he's
all-powerful there is not a single
moment of time where God can be stripped
of that power because that doesn't make
him good anymore if he's the all-knowing
there cannot be a time when he's
ignorant because that's he was never
stripped of his power he had his power
the whole time he just didn't he didn't
use it he didn't use it he chose that he
chose to honor what God wanted what the
father wanted which he is one with the
Father the Son the Holy Spirit which is
that energy that we talked about earlier
but that makes him weak the moment he
says that I choose to make myself suffer
that's a weakness that's not a strength
it's if I say I'm going to get a little
kid to slap me up or beat me up I'm not
showing my power if I go to Mike Tyson
and I go Mike
show me how strong you he goes okay how
you want me to show you how no no let me
punch you in the face don't punch me
back does that show how strong he is or
how weak he is it will actually look
stupid if I said to him let me punch you
in the nose don't punch me back if
you're a real man if you show me how
strong you are no he'll knock me out
because he'll say I'll show you my power
my my strength so the the thing that
we're just saying here is that he's all
powerful but at one moment he got
crucified it's consistent it's
consistent with his messaging his
message was always respond peacefully
turn the other cheek forgive those who
wrong you it was never fight back
I understand but that shows his to me
what it is we're talking about God so
Jesus is fine the message is fine it's
all peace and love I understand I
understand that for Jesus what is God's
representative so that was God's message
he was but for example you have a an
individual called Melchizedek in the
Bible I think it's in Hebrews chapter 7
verse three and he says Melchizedek has
no father no mother he has no beginning
and no end so the thing is then if he
has those attributes do we now say okay
now mountuz is also good because you see
where it goes it opens the kind of worms
where we all we see is God Almighty it
does not befit him to walk like a man a
man has to eat and he gets tired and he
goes sleep he has to also go and use the
toilet we say that is doesn't befit the
one who you know that picture we solved
the universe can you imagine the one
that created that crane to Earth in that
spec and ate food and went to the toilet
we say it doesn't benefit his majesty
like he's so glorious that I cannot
fathom to say that he became a man and
and by the way like for example there is
no evidence in in the Bible to say that
he claimed Divinity like there's
discussion about iron if you see the
father you saw me I am a father of one
but talking about essence of God he just
contradicts his Essence that's where
we're coming from as Muslims yeah and I
disagree because I think that it it
really take it it takes a tremendous
amount of love for his children or as
you would say his creation uh to come
down here
and walk among us and I think that it is
actually a really beautiful way for him
to do that and for him to give us
something to relate to and somebody to
talk to like we talk to a person but
learn in a whole different way and
I don't think it debases God I think it
shows his his the depth of his mercy and
willing to love and sacrifice for us
that he would step out of that Divinity
and and sit with us and that's what
Jesus did too on a on a on just a manly
even just as a man just the man part
forget the god part for a second he went
to the bad neighborhoods
he's out with the tax collectors and the
prostitutes and the Beggars and the
lepers
and so if he's doing that he was doing
that to teach us that God would even
bring him a piece of himself down here
and sit among us who we do not deserve
that we do not deserve to sit with God
none of us are good enough and he said
I'm gonna come sit with you anyway so
that's how I see that I don't see it as
being debasing at all I see it as being
a beautiful like a mother would
sit with her sick child and never leave
its side
Sunny what's what's your take on it like
what do you think
much I've kind of just I know sorry guys
sorry where have you been like in your
in your search for like where are you at
like do you are you an atheist
no I'm not an atheist
um I grew up you know we didn't really
grow up going to church I went to
Catholic High School and you know to be
honest in school I never really paid too
much attention I took a scripture and
everything but none of it really
resonated with me at all I mean some of
it did like some little specific points
but for the most part I I've never like
felt the urge to go to church of my own
even the first time that I um what was
it is
uh
what's it called communion communion no
not communion confirmation confirmation
yeah it's a 10th grade
when I went to confirmation it's like in
the church it's like the 90 year old
dude that you know reads the Bible
doesn't do any interpretation so you
don't know what's going on and um I
would like I was such a little crap I
got kicked out of confirmation the first
time he got kicked out of confirmation
class and I have this two-page single
space typed hilarious letter from the
church and I was so I was so bad I just
thought it was funny I was like this kid
I mean because he's just a Class Clown
and it wasn't flying
let me ask you a question what Sonny
what does when you think about God what
does how do you see God as like in your
that point Islam Christianity all this
aside like all of them to a side
what do you see God as like well to you
what's it who is God
I see God as more of like an it sounds I
guess it sounds weird but in my brain to
try to explain it it's more like an
energy
so it's
I don't know because what I've really
been digging into a lot lately is like
Consciousness and trying to truly
understand what is consciousness because
like it's not just your brain like your
body is essentially I don't know is it a
shell or is it truly you like what
actually are you as a conscious being
you know
um I've thought a lot about time so how
time what could have possibly happened
first nothing so time is essentially
just relative if it goes back infinitely
and goes forward infinitely so I see God
is something that you can't really like
fully wrap your mind around truly of
like what God really is so I kind of see
it more as an energy and I think that
the way we were Wired from when we were
little is to kind of keep us and even a
lot of the stuff that goes on is to keep
our brains trapped so I think that
oh I don't know I I've had some
experience with psychedelics and I feel
like that it sounds crazy and I know it
you sound like a crazy hippie but it
makes you see that stuff really
differently and you can almost see the
different energy you can feel the
different energy levels to an extent
where when you're in your normal your
normal self you you don't I don't know
it's hard to you don't feel those things
and you can though just so you know
through meditation deep meditation and
prayer you can feel those things but I I
haven't yet yeah
so you see God just as an energy like is
that like
is that what you just seem like
essentially so like you you know
obviously like if I do good in the world
and I have good intentions I agree like
that that good comes back around I think
you know so that's that's more like the
The Works of God but what about himself
God himself
would you give it up for example if I
look at a painting I look at the
painting and I go okay number one I
acknowledge that somebody will this
patent to come number two there's an
individual number three it's beautiful
so he's good at what he does
um so I will give some attributes by
looking at the painting So when you look
at around us and the creation for
example is there any attributes that you
give them or do you see because some
people you can see them are just like
image I just believe it's just a power
source or do you or do you give more
than that is it more like a personal
go-to or is it more just like something
there like right some see that some see
the old the old man with the white beard
no yeah you know on the throne on a
cloud you know when I was little I think
that's what all the kids think because
that's what's portrayed on TV and stuff
it's like the men sitting in the clouds
but at this point I don't see that at
all I don't know I don't I feel like I'm
not praying if I do to a person I I
don't even know how to explain it to be
quite honest like it's kind of I feel
like it's it's like explaining colors to
a blind person to try to explain God you
know what I mean interesting okay well
one question to your mom
um if argument's sake if he was to
accept Islam argument saying
how
how would you feel and how would you
like what would it mean to you like just
hypothetically if he was cool yeah I
think that I think the answer to that
question will change as I continue on
this path and learn more but right now
today uh I I I would
I would be supportive because
I love him and I want what's best for
him and if he's living a you know the
right life like a really walk in a
straight path and doing the right things
and staying away from you know gambling
in drugs and alcohol and all the things
I you know I would be supportive but it
would it would make me sad because
for me you know my Christianity is
becoming such a big part of my life that
it's something I want to share with him
and I want to experience it with him as
a family and also just you know the
culturally you know people say people
will go back hundreds of years and tell
me I know Sicily yeah you know the Moors
are there whatever that I'm just talking
about the last few generations of my
family the last four or five generations
was just like Italians Italian you know
a couple Generations ago they moved to
America so we're just a sicilian
Catholic you know rituals and holidays
that we celebrate that really are
important and for me they're in my DNA
and I would feel like he he would be
then disconnected from his ancestors
and that matters to me because culture
you know it doesn't matter as much as
God
but it does matter yeah and I think it's
really good for Humanity for us to have
you know culture and traditions
so I would struggle it would hurt me but
not enough to put a rift between us like
I will let nothing come between us
yeah nice understandable yeah my mom's
always been supportive of me even my
even though when my dad was really
hostile my mum's always been there like
she's supported me yeah so yeah and I
don't think his dad would be hostile
either you know I think his dad would
also be kind of like how I am you know
maybe it would have less so but he would
he would you know you've got to make
sure you know I just I would have to
explain it obviously you know yeah yeah
and I'm glad I just hope that you'll
explore as you're exploring this you
know you'll explore you know other
avenues and really find the one that's
right for you and when you're 19 maybe
you are old enough to you know you
aren't old enough but maybe you will
come to conclusions now but this is a
journey that may take a while too it
takes like you you've only been you know
10 years I looked into three and a half
years like Bible Islam differently is is
a is a journey yeah yeah and it's a
beautiful journey I think working no
matter what you end up believing again I
think I think that these just may be
different paths to the same place does
Islam believe in like a third eye almost
because there's some times where I feel
like I'm just walking around and stuff
just feels like dull to an extent so
almost like brain fog but it feels like
there's like a third wall in front of my
eyes that it's like allowing me to just
not see stuff for what it truly is do
you know what I mean so so like I feel
like I can't have a true connection with
stuff around me even when I'm like
walking in nature I'm like I don't know
it sounds weird to be honest the I don't
know about the food I think I don't know
exactly what that is about we like we in
the Quran Allah says that's
indeed in the remembrance of God do
hearts find peace and another verse it
says if you forget my remembrance you
will have a depressed life so what we
believe as Muslims is that we have the
fitra the fitra is the innate
disposition so this is what kind of one
of the reasons I came to Islam because
there was a study done in Oxford
University by Justin Barrett so what he
did is he got young kids and he had an
experiment where he realized that all
these young kids if you put Islam and
all these religions to a site don't tell
them nothing about it they have an
inclination to Worship in a God yeah so
to me that was like very profound
because what that shows is that if I
woke up on the Amazon jungle I would
worship God I would not worship Muhammad
Jesus Moses Ganesh anybody I haven't
innate this position to find God so this
is what's really unique to me with Islam
because it was like wow I could be a
Muslim without Islam in that context
that's fascinating yeah so what is that
called is the fittler the innate
disposition so that's why when he was
talking about you know was having a you
know a little mini debate with your uh
with your dear mom may Allah blessed uh
guider and the thing is and that's when
I was saying can God cease to exist he's
like no because that's the federal
saying of course not can God lie of
course not so what we see is these are
the things God has programmed us with to
find him do you get it like sometimes
when something doesn't make sense we're
like oh yeah that doesn't make sense but
we have a leap of faith so sometimes
when I speak to people like I was
speaking to a Buddhist he's like yeah
they believe in this guy who claims to
be divine and I said do you really
believe that and he was like yeah it
doesn't make sense but I'm like okay but
you know he doesn't make yeah you know
because it's your innate this position
and waking you up so what you're talking
about that fog is like it goes to our
day-to-day life we will never find
happiness that's why when I came from my
lifestyle of copying partying girls
it was never fulfilling you know why
just as the body requires food and drink
and sleep the soul requires soul food
yeah what that means is your soul
requires the remembrance of God that is
the only way you find happiness that's
why we tend to go from the cycle of
chasing I know if I have the hottest
girlfriend I'll be happy no it's not
making me happy there's someone more
beautiful if I have this car if I have
that the soul is craving and wanting the
need of God but we are feeding at the
wrong food so what it does when you give
the stomach the wrong food it vomits it
it takes it back out because they're
saying this is not good for me so the
soul is doing the same thing that's why
you see so many people going through
depression anxiety because you're giving
the the soul the wrong food and only in
the remembrance of God would your heart
find peace so that's why to me when a
person acknowledges the sweet we call it
the sweetness of faith
when you have that they can take the
whole world from you you're like I don't
need that it's it's this I cannot
explain about I know that I'm saying I
have it by the way I'm not trying to
sound privacy but when you have that you
realize that that is the only thing that
you ever needed that is the only thing
you ever needed you know
um and yeah but I think that's what it
might be I'm saying maybe it's what
you're saying about I can't see things
clearly maybe maybe it might be that I
love everything you just said and it and
I and I want to you know reiterate it
but add to it that so that that feeling
that like uh
you know if what what we call on the
Practical side uh intuition a lot of
that time is God talking to you and so
when you get back in touch and you
refocus on God like he's saying that
that feeling comes comes to life again
because he's there he's present in your
gut and in your in your you could feel
your soul you could feel him talking to
you so when you have that and you're
walking in nature you you suddenly just
are more open and it's and you and
connected it gets rid of that third law
that you're talking about God makes that
third law just evaporate yeah so I'm I'm
pretty into the red pill stuff but not
in the typical manosphere way where it's
like you know the way they look at women
like I'm more in like the Matrix sense
where I just want to wake up and like
really find the truth because I feel
like I've been so programmed and the
more I dig it's it goes so much deeper
than I even thought like I was watching
videos about Consciousness Consciousness
last night and I was watching about how
well even the way we just percept things
has to do with like multiples of under
four and it's like we're taught that
since we're little and that even just
it's such a innate wiring in your brain
something little like that as to how you
look at anything so it goes so deep and
it's it's weird a marketing media yeah
what they teach us in school for which
textbook you get is going to determine
how you see something and everything and
so we are programmed like computers and
yeah that's the great like d programmer
yeah if you've been told how to think
how do you have a choice that's why I
always say don't have a choice really uh
all these programming and all this stuff
that you watch doesn't have an impact on
your decision factors but you know
people who who are anti-religion will
say that we're we're programmed yeah
yeah yeah
like you said we don't deny the
programming we say we'd rather be
programmed by God
yeah because it's the Creator thank you
because it makes that makes sense
because I totally agree like all these
liberals and stuff that are pushing for
all these crazy agendas that's what
they're idolizing is abortions and being
you know sleeping around and all of that
stuff that's what they idolize and
that's so unfulfilling I mean those
they're not happy they're all they get
depressed and then they go to the doctor
and even the Doctor Who you see is as
the verified truth is now telling them
to take a pill and that losing weight
getting a better diet so I'm like like
this is what I've grown up to see as
innate truth and to trust and I'm like I
just see all of it as such a scam
nowadays you know what I mean and I even
look at stuff like I'm sorry to cut you
off but
even stuff like the Mind gut connection
where I always felt something like that
where if I I leave the house and I feel
something in my gut it's like what did I
forget and then I go back and I see it
right away it's little stuff like that
where I'm never taught any of it it just
feels like everything with school
everything was just to program me so
even if it's not in the sense of like
I'm trying to find the truth and you
know what prophet said this I'm just
trying to find the actual truth of
what's around me do you know what I mean
yeah but by the way yeah I apologize for
cutting you I was cutting you not the
other way around by the way yeah so
forgive me I was trying to call you yeah
it's like you said you know even I'm
reading a book called um irreversible
damage you know I'm reading it too oh
it's yeah so the thing is it's it's it's
crazy that 16 year old girl there who
I mean amputating yourself for the
transgender girl yeah yeah
it's it's about it's about
um it's about this transgender push on
teenagers and how
um basically it's being used as escapism
you know because being a teenager is
weird a weird time in life and it can be
difficult and so they're just giving
kids a kids a place to go where then
they feel like they have some control
and they can get out of it and then
they're end up being just as suicidal or
even more suicidal than they were before
they they they became more suicidal
after so the thing is you're going to
these doctors and these doctors are just
you know these prescriptions they give
you they get money out of that so how
could you even trust somebody who has
got a different agenda and you're going
in for help oh can you help me I feel
like this oh I know the solution is you
know why do you take these hormones so
like your mom said as well your dear
mother said you know that and it's very
similar to Islam which is that Allah
says in the Quran have you seen the one
who takes his desires as his own God
this is it that we're facing today
people are taking their desires as their
God literally whatever I want to do I
want to do it and that corrupts your
soul you know you're not meant to have
anything and everything you want your
game I'm trying to say some things that
are earned taste the sweetest so yeah
it's it's yeah sadly we live in this 100
and that's just not what we're taught
like even with the like failure in
school you're you're literally taught
that you need to get stuff right on the
first time and if you fail you get
punished for it you're not taught that
you need to like just try and almost go
for failure so that you can learn from
it and then you know you look at how
that affects your business life and
you're like you need to fail in business
and that's just not the way you're
you're wired so it's so much deeper like
it goes into every aspect of life it's
failure that makes you successful I mean
when you go to the gym you're training
to failure it's those failures that make
you big you know we we need the failures
otherwise we'll never have success no
exactly it goes with everything and
that's why even listening to like Andrew
Tate because he says a lot of the same
stuff that I feel like we all innately
believe and it's just changed the way I
look at life so much even like you know
like stress is a good thing you know you
don't always like it's going for just
happiness all the time that doesn't make
any sense because you need to have
negativity in your life to truly enjoy
that happiness of course of course you
know
don't be silly I'll get passionate I'm
so sorry finish your sentence no I was
going to say if all you do is look for
happiness that's more empty inside you
know but if you look at you know if
you're going through a negative time as
a good thing because once you experience
that happiness that's even better and
you're you know you're building blocks
for yourself like when I have a kid and
they get injured or something I'm gonna
like celebrate it and I'm gonna teach
them from the very start that like only
reps that count in the gym are the ones
that hurt you know what I mean like when
you're doing like your 10 reps and then
it starts to hurt that's when you do
more when you're going through a
struggle and you know homework or
business like that's the only time it
matters you know none of the other stuff
when it's easy that doesn't mean
anything you know that's interesting
there's a verse in the Quran Allah says
verily with hardship comes is indeed
with hardship comes East which is
interesting because it's like why does
God have to repeat the same statement
again unless it's something called Deep
and important right in life yeah if
think about it if if hardship comes ease
the opposite is true with ease comes
hardship yes right point is that we live
in such ease we live like kings I can
open my fridge and I've got orange juice
cranberry juice water
um oat milk and we Kings did not live
like us and this ease causes Us in the
long run to have hardship that's the
reason why when it comes to training
like you said I I'll tell my wife if I
was ever ever have a son you know a
three years old I'm going to start you
know giving little Jabs you know here
and there because you have to look at
if you looked at how his father brought
him up you would say this man is
torturing call the police somebody
called the um uh child support or
something
but if you look at how he turned out
because the hardship that you give in
the long run gives you ease and the when
you do the opposite and give anything to
your children I mean look at kids when
you spoil them yeah and give them
whatever they want how do they turn up
they don't appreciate nothing yeah
exactly so this concept with hardship
comes is you can apply this anywhere and
you see the results whatever it is
training with your partner whoever it is
you see the fruits of it later
yeah and I I just it makes perfect sense
and I just see so many traps nowadays to
keep people down like even with like a
phone like this is the biggest trap of
of them all because you don't give
yourself the chance to sit down and even
think you know what I mean like no one
has original thoughts anymore and I was
just talking to my friend in the Army
and he said how for you know for during
basic training when they didn't have
their phone for weeks he said stories
that he hasn't thought of in in years
were just flying back to him and I'm
like God like that's so crazy because
anytime someone's bored nowadays even
for a second at a dinner where you're
talking to someone you just look at your
phone and half of the time I feel like
I'm looking at my phone I mean at least
I'm acknowledging it and I'm trying to
break it but I'm just like opening
Instagram scrolling through the DMS
nothing exactly I'm not doing anything
doing it have you have you done this
before like I realized to myself it
becomes a habit so you've got open one
app open another and you do that you
turn off and you do the same thing I've
done it and I've done it subconsciously
and I was like
that yeah I didn't really do I didn't
willingly do that I went to the same
apps in in sync like one after another
and I thought why am I doing that it's
just like a pattern it's like Instagram
yeah and I was like oh my gosh it was
scary it was scary it was like is it me
am I making this is not no but you you
have to know like it's it's so it must
be so intentional by the people who
created this actually no there's you
there are documentaries and studies you
can very easily run easily available to
look at and see that they made very
specific programming choices in order to
get us addicted I've heard plenty of old
philosopher quotes about how they you
know keep people's minds distracted and
um keep them weak and there's nothing
that they can do they can't stand up for
anything you know yeah yeah that's why
especially yeah oh sorry go ahead I was
just gonna say it's a wonderful
wonderful time to be alive because this
is this kind of thing has been going on
all throughout history of controlling
people with narratives in different ways
and now we just have the technology they
create created the technology to keep
the masses in their phones and stupid
but there's also this technology has
this other effect of being able to
spread knowledge and awaken people from
this programming and this thing and it's
it's slow because the damage is so deep
it's not going to be easy but it is a
cool time to be alive and watch some
people come awake from from this this
you know trance a lot of people don't
even want to be awakened though you know
that's the crazy thing
yeah wow that's all right there we know
where they're going right I don't know
they cover that what were you gonna say
I'm sorry yeah
something I love that if we're
interrupting each other that means we're
all excited yeah to contribute and I
really appreciate those sorry my phone
my phone's barking all right
um I saw one of your shorts I wanted to
bring this up I don't know if you this
might just go take too long is it a
feminist one
um sort of yeah which one is that it was
about women having to sleep with their
husbands yeah yeah you probably get
questions on this one all the time
yeah go on what's the question
no so I just wanted to talk about that
because that's one of the things that
you mentioned before and you were like
that sounds crazy and I I see both sides
to be honest because I I I heard your
full point but then I could also see
what you're gonna say it's like you know
you just because you protect me doesn't
mean I have to give you [ __ ] when oh
sorry for swearing but right because I
don't see I don't all right so so the
conversation and correct me if I'm wrong
was you know that they're that the wife
has an obligation if her husband wants
you know relations to give it to him and
if not she's going to be cursed by
Angels okay I was like I you know I
bristled at that
um the explanation was he has an
obligation to provide and so to to
protect you if somebody comes and pulls
a knife on you in the street you know he
has an obligation to protect his wife
and I and I agree that she does but that
doesn't and you know and an obligation
to protect personal safety does not
equal an obligation to
um satisfy a a desire you know it's uh
that that's not an absolute necessity
you know life so
and and as a woman I can tell you
that um
if you're not in the mood
or you have a physical problem or
there's any reason Under the Sun that
you don't want to do that it is it it's
violating
it's not it's and and it should never be
that way and to me that sounds really
disrespectful to women and to say that
I'm going to be cursed by Angels you
know what I've met a lot of men I'd
rather be cursed thanks anyway keep
moving you know what I'm saying so it
really I think it's I think it's an
obligation of both Partners in a
marriage to make themselves
you know loved and attractive to each
other and to be kind and respectful of
what is supposed to be a beautiful
moment of intimacy so I really bristled
at that video but please respond you
know yeah so that video is a short story
if you watch the full video uh in the
full video
um you can see that this is talking
about a woman that's manipulating a man
using intimacy so um I'll read you
something so basically I I believe that
the greatest inequality is to treat
unequal things equally
if that makes sense yeah the greatest
inequality is to treat unequal things
equally so here's what the studies which
is kind of what I just said like the
feminism and you said that protecting
personal safety and and satisfying an
urge to not yeah so like should not be
treated equally because they're not okay
so so the point here is the following so
before I go into let me just read the
study the study says the sex drive
refers to the strength of sexual
motivation across many different studies
and measures men have shown to have more
frequent and more more intense sexual
desires than women as reflected in
spontaneous thoughts about sex frequency
of frequency of variety of sexual
fantasies desired frequency of
intercourse desired number of Partners
masturbation lacking for various sexual
practices willing Mr Fogo sex initiating
versus refusing sex making sacrifices
for sex and other measures no contrary
findings indicating stronger sexual
motivation among women were found now
the study shows that I've read similar
studies yeah
roughly common knowledge yeah so so men
and women are different they have for us
the opposite gender and sexual our
sexual urges are much higher than a
woman so what was what I was saying is
the following
this is talking about which I've
mentioned I had a discussion a couple of
years ago with a another lady from
America actually she was mentioning this
as well so that is this Hadith is
talking about a woman who is
manipulating a man using intimacy so
blackmailing him so we acknowledge that
if a woman is in a period menopause
she's not feeling well she's tired no
one in their right mind would ever say
no you have to because if you look at
the Hadith Hadith says what if the man
wants intimacy as a Muslim man we are
not allowed to be promiscuous we're not
allowed to sleep around we're not having
girlfriends and Mistresses we have a
wife we come back to we work hard we
provide for them we love them we come
home and imagine coming home and then
your wife is saying no because she's
being malicious not I'm tired today
which man in their right mind will say
no I don't care if you're tired or
you've been looking after the kids or
your new Menses no that is valid reasons
all right so malice is different malice
is now you're just being a witch
yeah she's what she's doing is the
following I am going to use this your
greatest desire against you and not give
you what you want unless you do
arguments say a b and c a lot of women
do that yeah so the Hadith is talking
about that which I mentioned to her I
said look this is It's these exceptions
are fine now when we talk about a man
the when I give the example of a man in
a situation where if somebody pulls out
a knife the comparison I made was the
following one in one instance the man is
willing to die for you he's willing to
put his life on the line the point was
he's willing to die for you not I'm
doing this for you I want that it's like
as a husband he loves you so much that
he's willing to die for you and when he
wants intimacy you say no for no
Advantage reasons but be malicious so
the argument wasn't hey I've done a
therefore you need to give me this even
if you're tired it wasn't that if you
watch the full video it was that men and
women
um woman is in a most vulnerable state
when it comes to physical combat so a
man has to perform
because she's physically not well if I
turn around and said oh I don't feel I
don't uh sorry I I do not want to defend
you know you go do what you want either
called a coward and if she was to be
harmed be it being punished in the face
or being harmed I would be called out
for it you're stronger than her why
would you her family will beat me up her
family will say we entrusted our
daughter so so the point is when we look
at it from the opposite Spectrum a man
is most vulnerable when it comes to
intimacy so when he's coming to his wife
and avoiding and lowering his gaze and
not looking at other women and not being
promiscuous and he wants intimacy and
she says no not because of a valid
reason but because I'm going to be
malicious that is why the angels are
cursing her not because oh I'm tired I'm
not I'm not feeling well Hadith doesn't
say that just to be uh all right yeah I
owe you an apology and I oh it's my
fault and I and I owe myself a slap on
the wrist right short form content for
you right it's because I I judged you on
that and I and I know I want to let me
apologize because they truly I truly I'm
sorry and I and and I really appreciate
that clarification and my slap on the
wrist of myself is shame on me because
all I talk about all the time is don't
don't believe short form content things
to easily taken out of context and
twisted and that's really what it in
that short it's provocative
because it it really doesn't explain it
the way you just did but that's why I
get so many views so shame on me for
shame on me for uh you know following
for breaking my own Rule and and thank
you for understanding right and I would
I would actually say I don't blame you I
would personally say I think it's maybe
my fault because I didn't add the
clarification so I was wondering upon
this I might even take it down because
in the video in the full video I give
the clarification but the way my editor
edited it
um I thought that it didn't do justice
so I'm actually to blame for making
because you watch the snippet I could
have not put that snippet so it's
actually I'm the one to be ashamed and I
should give myself one two three slabs
on my wrist because I didn't yes it's
correct because we have to be just
because if I'm causing suspicion that's
my fault and I I'm actually I might even
take the video down today and probably
gives clarification properly because
you're trying to shed you're trying to
shed a positive light uh and a welcoming
light on Islam and drama people in and
that you know I versus results so I I'm
so so grateful for your clarification
and I'm grateful thank you that's cool
I'm grateful that you gave me that
feedback because it shows me like I
don't sometimes think does my videos
reach I think maybe Muslims watch it the
fact that it reached you to shows me
that I have more responsibility to be
very careful what I share because that
discussion is a 24 minute of a 24 minute
discussion and none of the comments
actually said that but on the shorts the
feedback was different just as like you
said because it's my fault I didn't put
the entire clarification so I am to
blame you and I will fix it thanks for
giving me feedback yeah the thing though
is giving clarification in short form
content then the video doesn't do as
well so this kind of leads me on to
another question I had on what do you
think about
um like click bait and let's say you
know if you use the strategy like that
where you purposely didn't give all the
context for the video to go more viral
but then you directed people to the the
full video what are your thoughts on
that is that okay okay I've known I'm
known as um some people think I've done
my PhD in clickbait uh so basically a
lot of people because I'm known as a
clickbait king yeah okay now when it
comes to clickbait we have to be very
careful because as Muslims we are not
allowed to lie so my clickbaits are I
put true statements there so the
statement is true but like for example I
did one I would recommend you to watch
it yeah it's called Ali and his wife
gets a new house yeah so in my
background in the thumbnail it's it
looks like a bungalow it looks like it
looks like we moved on to a new house
but I actually showed the grave and I go
this our Eternal home
so so GC is like it's it's interesting
but so when it comes to clickba a lot of
people complain as well sometimes oh
you're doing clickbait but sometimes
it's like it can work as long as you're
not lying to me it's like as long as the
statement's true you know what you're
saying it's um it's not big of an issue
but obviously you have to be careful
because at the end of the day sometimes
people like I do click baits because I
want people to benefit of the content
some people get click baits because it's
like oh I need to make more money on
YouTube I need more views Etc so it's to
me it's like I want the maximum amount
of people to benefit from that video so
for example I would use a clip of our
discussion here at our discussion here
and I will write
um what if Sonny became a Muslim
question mark so it's kind of oh my gosh
did you become a Muslim and then it's
your mom's feedback saying okay if you
did this is how a relationship will be
so do you see where it's like or Mom
reacts to Sun converting to Islam and
then people will click on it and then
it's the hypothetical no I know I know
exactly what you mean and I that's
personally what I would say is like it's
it's cutting a little bit of the
Integrity for an overall good because
then people click on the video and then
they see what you're truly talking about
so all you really did was get them to
click on it in a dis a semi dishonest
way I did the same thing with the Andrew
Tate videos reaction videos at first I
don't know if you watched any of them
but I made the thumbnails be like sexist
misogynist yeah and then in the video
we're just giving giving our real
thoughts but we just knew that that
would get more views you know it's
marketing and and God like just the
whole reason we got here was to talk
about Islam and Christianity and like
God God's a marketer too right you know
if you think about it Miracles
prophecies uh you know that's all
marketing on his own part and you know
as long as we do in in his good intent
is in it and so if your intent is still
good like you're saying back we talked
you talked about it in depth uh I I
think it's I think it's okay if no one's
getting hurt and and your intentions are
good
and the outcome is good and you're
shepherding God's money the way it
brings you money that you Shepherd and
you're a good Steward of it
oh wow well we should probably get going
it's been a long conversation and it's
late for you yeah we went right through
your dinner didn't we that's fine I'm
meeting I'm doing one meal a day uh Omar
to diet so um my wife's going to be
cooking so don't worry but thank you
look it was it was a pleasure
um at the end of the day this is how it
needs to be both face Muslim Christian
Jews talk and discuss you know I don't
like when things get hostile we our job
is to convey you know so it was nice we
had a discussion we had a little mini
debate you know we agreed to disagree
it's as simple as that you move on you
know so it's I hope it's a fine example
to show that people from two different
worlds two different countries two
different worlds religious religion that
they come together have a discussion
people learn you take what you take you
leave the good and take the um you take
the hood and leave the bad and yeah it
was a pleasure it was really nice
meeting you I was gonna actually get my
mom to come by snowing here so uh she
couldn't I was gonna be like me and my
mom and you know uh speak but yeah maybe
some other time we can do that because
that would be fun that I would love to
meet your mom and if we get get out
there we'll do it live
yeah no problem thank you for your time
yeah hope you have enjoyed your sunny
weather we'll be enjoying the snow here
uh but yeah that's it if you have any
questions anything you need I'm here at
your service thank you for your time
same here thank you so much so much I
definitely have more to talk about so
we'll do another call
okay no problem anytime thank you thank
you bye bye